host amy schumer is bringing a little
behind-the-scenes access to what happens
live telling andy cohen what it felt
like being backstage when smith won for
best actor
everything has been said about the thing
that happened but i am there's one thing
that i'm wondering your opinion
about the thing hold on let me just take
a quick yeah right
so many people commented and it became a
big deal and i
i just wonder if you have any thoughts
about it about the standing ovation that
will got when he won the award did you
have any thoughts about that well i i'll
just say i was backstage and um and i
knew i had to go out i was kind of the
only host that was going out solo after
that so it really felt like the
situation room
you know like of comedy like we were all
just like watching the monitor and we're
like and then he won and we're all like
like everybody just we're just everybody
was just kind of floored for the whole
thing and yeah um
yeah and i was just thinking like about
how am i gonna what am i gonna do
well yeah and that wasn't the only
moment that uh amy spoke about sharing
her thoughts on the sweetest moment of
the night
everyone's talked about the slap but
there were so many moments that got kind
of overlooked because of it one of which
i love that i was wondering your
feedback on
i loved when lady gaga
said to liza i got you i got you that
was so sweet that was one of my favorite
moments and just seeing them together
backstage i love how lady gaga just like
is so there yeah for
you know
people who are a little older than us
right now
yeah you know she's just i get that too
you know there's people who are sweet
she really was gentle and patient and
you know yes i love that
i fully agree that's one of the i what
it is one of the things that i do love
the most about lady gaga yeah which is
she built this fantastic relationship
she was at the height of pop
the height like you you there had been
in a generation there hadn't been
somebody who achieved lady gaga did and
then she developed what she developed
with tony bennett yeah and it was just
so like it's so beautiful like it's so
great and then even with liza minnelli
like you get a sense from lady gaga that
she understands more than anybody where
she is in the sort of moment but she
also has incredible respect for history
yeah and then they make a really good
point i mean there's some really great
highlights at this year's oscars and you
missed those points because of that
situation i actually went back after the
grammys to watch quest love's uh speech
and it was beautiful like it was a
moment him
talking about his dad and his mom being
there and you could feel and i'm like i
think i need to go back just to watch
these special moments that happen that
we completely missed right um so it's
good that he acknowledged that there
were other moments that we should have
celebrated at the time right
comments no comments um here we have
lady gaga's amazing with tony and with
liza
uh can you have trish stratus on the
show
yeah we've had trish on here before
church is the bomb
uh oh what what is this yes everybody
gets slapped all the time i'm sure roz
slaps someone this week also
what is that
what is going on
okay that's the highlight today none of
your business
mind your business